colin kaepernick celebrates on
thanksgiving the new york times op-ed
page defends woke conspiratorial ISM and
Britain is hit with another terror
attack I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show the Ben Shapiro show is
sponsored by expressvpn protect your
online privacy today and expressvpn comm
slash man now you may have been noticing
some volatility in the markets may have
also been noticing some people making
estimates over stock prices next year
now might be a good time to diversify
some of your investments particularly in
precious metals now you know Birch gold
has been with me since the very
beginning they were literally our very
first advertiser on this show and
they're putting out an offer this
holiday season that I haven't seen
before and I've known them for quite a
while it is the silver stocking stuffer
event that five times fast when you
contact Birch gold group this month to
buy precious metals once you complete
your purchase before December 20th Birch
gold will send you free silver which is
a great stocking stuffer or Hanukkah
gifts I mean how would you like to see
that in your stock you just open them
there's silver inside open your account
with Birch gold group today get free 100
percent silver have a conversation with
the Birch gold expert ask all of your
questions and all of your questions
answered be an informed investor and
then think about diversify into precious
metals at least a little bit I'm not
saying liquidate all of your stock
holdings and just buy bars of gold I'm
saying you should take some of your
money and you should put it in an
alternative to the stock market because
you just never know where the stock
market is going to go and it's good to
be diversified in general you have
nothing to lose to take that first step
call up Birch gold group they have
thousands of satisfied customers
countless five-star reviews an A+ rating
with the Better Better Business Bureau
it's worth it just X been to 47 47 47
claim your eligibility for their special
offer today again that's been - 47 47 47
text Ben - 47 47 47 alrighty so I have a
lot to get to today first let me just
say it is the most wonderful time of the
year for crapping on America apparently
apparently it is that time of the year
see we are approaching a 20 20 an
election and as we approach that 2020
election it is apparent that in order to
gain the huzzah zuv the mainstream media
in order to receive praise from the
mainstream media all you really have to
do is take a dump all over the systems
that have created prosperity and
liberalism and freedom in the West if
you do that then the media will praise
you endlessly because our media
unfortunately are populated with people
who don't have a proper understanding of
American history many of them read
Howard Zinn's People history of the
United States and think they know things
now even though that history is taken
out of context and is completely
meritless in terms of its general
worldview this is the way that a lot of
people in the United States particularly
media think and what this means is that
you're seeing even presidential
candidates having to pay homage to this
sort of worldview well the latest to do
this as people who teachers now again
Buddha jej his draw is that he's been
running as a moderate in the past couple
of months he started off his campaign
running as a moderate then he swiveled
to the left in an attempt to grab that
woke base and then when that failed he
swivel back to the center and he started
picking up in the polls and right now
he's leading in Iowa and he's doing well
in New Hampshire as well Elizabeth
Warren conversely she started off as the
sort of rational alternative to Bernie
Sanders
and then she skewed way out to the left
and started talking nationalized health
care and then she fell apart because
people don't like that sort of thing
well Buddha judge is making that same
mistake now the reason he's doing that
is because he traveled down to South
Carolina over the over the weekend and
he is trying to gain some black support
for his candidacy right now he has none
he's the whitest candidate in the race
or at least is perceived as such in
reality Elizabeth Warren is even whiter
because she's the whitest person who has
ever lived but he booted reg traveled
down to South Carolina he needs to start
making some inroads in the black vote
because the fact is that about
two-thirds of the South Carolina primary
base is black so the AP reports as he
Labor's to win over black voters whose
support is vital to his Democratic
presidential bid people to judge found a
receptive host on Sunday and a civil
rights activist who is sought to
continue Reverend Martin Luther King
Junior's pushed for racially diverse
national campaign against poverty after
attending services at Reverend William
barber Greenleaf Christian Church boo to
judge stayed for a discussion with the
Poor People's Campaign begun by King
shortly before his assassination in 1968
Barbour a pastor and former North
Carolina n-double-a-cp president revived
them out of the movement to unite a new
generation of Americans of all races to
combat economic inequality now this of
course was specifically designed in
order to win boo to judge some sort of
support he had had himself a rough week
after he was attacked by Michael Harriet
Michael Harriet Ann was this columnist
for the route
wrote a column about how people who
judge was a lying MF or why because
people who judge had suggested quite
reasonably back in 2011 that educational
inequality in the United States is not
entirely due to systemic factors much
educational inequality in the United
States is due to the fact that there are
a lot of kids who are growing up in
areas where they do not have parental
figures who are deeply ensconced in the
education system who are who are not
teaching them that education is in fact
a ladder out of poverty that was true
and he was ripped up and now by Michael
Harriet for that and now bootie judges
attempting to respond to that criticism
by basically it appears bowing before
the dictates of a sort of politically
correct woken Asst the michael harriet
who wrote this really this pair of
incredibly self-indulgent pieces which
were praised as brilliant and wonderful
because the more purple you're writing
is in the more you spice them with
meaningful parables and anecdotes the
more people think that you have
something important to say
well harriet was on MSNBC and he was
talking about bootie judge he said well
democrats have to know how to talk to
black voters now this is in and of
itself a bizarre contention because the
fact is democrats and republicans should
be talking to all voters presumably in
the same way because we're all
individuals the idea that you talk to a
black voter differently than you talk to
a Latino voter differently than you talk
to a white voter is really awful for our
politics if you are tailoring your
message specifically based on the race
of the people to whom you are speaking
that would be you being kind of racist
right if you are attempting to speak to
white audiences I mean reverse the races
and you see how true that says if you
spoke to white audiences differently
then you speak to black audiences then
this is presumably you being a racist
but according to Michael Harry you have
to tailor your message what does it mean
to tailor your message you're not
allowed to say true things if it's
offensive to certain groups of peoples
here's Michael Harriet saying this and
then we'll see people to judge doing
some of this here so here's Michael
Harriet of the route again a man who
wrote that people who judge was a lying
mf'er based on the fact that Buddha
judge made a perfectly rational
statement about educational inequality
of outcome in the United States and then
Buddha judge called him then he wrote
another piece about what a wonderful guy
Michael Harriet is Michael Harriet loves
him so Michael Harriet here he is
talking on MSNBC about how democratic
politicians really need to learn how to
speak to black populations there are
people and candidates who come from
in America where they don't have to
court the black vote they don't have to
appeal to black citizens they don't have
to appeal to black voters and they can
still get elected into the positions as
mayors of South Bend or to to Senator
but when they have to appeal to a wider
demographic they don't know how to speak
to black voters and they and sometimes
black voters can see that we can sense
that okay so what does it mean to speak
to black voters differently well people
who judge thinks that what that means is
nodding along when people say insane
things about the evils of the United
States so Reverend William barber is
sitting across from Buddha judge and he
starts lecturing him on the evils of the
United States and Buddha jej just sits
there and goes right along with it as
far as I can see and I don't see any
blowback from Buddha judge or an attempt
to correct the record here's William
barber jumping into a statement about
how people who are illegally entering
the United States from South of
America's border are reclaiming land
that was originally won by the United
States so it's legitimate therefore to
be an illegal immigrant whenever people
say we call people illegal aliens and
all these things that are not human I'm
certainly not Christian why can't we
just own in America that the some of the
people that are trying to come from
Mexico here are coming back to land we
stole and the reason we took the land is
because people wanted to keep their
slaves okay so the the mexican-american
war is a very controversial aspect of
American history there were folks like
Abraham Lincoln who are very much
opposed to the mexican-american war
because they believe that the
mexican-american war was designed to
admit new slave states to the Union okay
so that part is true but what Barbour
says there that illegal immigrants are
crossing the border because of some sort
of revenge play from 1848 is perfectly
insane and any sovereign country has to
be in control of their own borders
obviously but the fact that Buddha judge
is nodding along to that speaks of how
members of the left believe that they
have to appeal to various members of the
of the Democratic constituency in other
words the the intellectual base of the
left the stuff that starts on college
campuses and then filters out to the
media and then filters out to
so-called thought leaders in the
Democratic community it is quite
anti-american in certain aspects of how
it views American history and how it
used capitalism how it views Western
liberalism we'll get some more of that
in just one second first let's talk
about your sleep quality so the fact is
I had a wonderful weekend of sleep why
well not just because I didn't have to
get up early every morning in order to
come into work but also because I was
sleeping on that helix sleep mattress I
mean you talk about a great Christmas
gift you're talking about something that
you can get for somebody for the
holidays that they are going to enjoy
like all the time
that is your helix sleep mattress why
because it is personalized to you Hewett
sleep has a quiz that takes just two
minutes to complete it matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you send a matter
how you sleep on your side on your back
hot sleeper whatever heel it can make
what your body needs just go to helix
sleep calm so I spent a clear two
minutes sleep quiz they will match you
to a customized mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life for
couples helix can even split that
mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and feel
preferences for each side they've got a
10 year warranty you can try it out for
a hundred nights at risk-free so what
the hell do you have to lose the answer
isn't nothing helix is offering up to
125 dollars off all mattress orders for
our listeners and up to 125 bucks off
and helix sleep comm slash pen that's
helix sleep comm slash pen for up to 125
dollars off your mattress order helix
sleep comm slash pen best sleep of your
life go check them out right now helix
sleep comm slash pen okay so that
perspective that you saw there from
reverence from Reverend William barber
and that is being not along to buy pee
Buddha judge unfortunately that
perspective is gaining credence in
certain parts of the American population
up broken down by race but broken down
by politics and that is deeply negative
it's why you see people like Colin
Kaepernick being granted all sorts of
endless media time for his for his
virtue signaling stupidity running a
wide variety of topics so for example
Colin Kaepernick over the weekend who
again retains his fame only because the
media keep covering his various
anti-american protests whether he's
putting pigs on his socks or whether
he's saying that the Betsy Ross flag is
racist
well his latest bid for attention since
he obviously doesn't want to play
quarterback in the NFL he trashed the
United States on on Thanksgiving Day
which I guess is sort of like your
unbirthday in Alice in Wonderland a very
merry on Thanksgiving Day two
you he said that he was accusing in the
United States of having stolen billions
of acres of land from indigenous people
and then he released a video on his
Twitter account to to play into all of
this so here is colin kaepernick a
millionaire thanks to the Western system
he is currently criticizing in America a
country that he apparently really does
not like in many ways here he is cutting
a video on Unthank skinning day because
apparently we're not supposed to be
thankful to God that we live in this
country we're not supposed to be
thankful to God that Western
civilization arrived on these shores
we're supposed to pretend that
everything would have been better for
the world if Europeans had never come to
the continent they which again that is
not to discount any of the evils
Europeans committed when arriving on
this continent but to pretend that the
world would be a better place broadly
speaking if Europe Ian's had never
colonized the United States is to be
completely ignorant of world history
economics and pretty much everything
else here's Colin Kaepernick doing that
routine presumably well leaning back in
his mansion and watching this thing
found his on his Twitter account created
on his iPhone for that 50 years before
that 50 years it will continue from this
point it's our responsibility to honor
our ancestors and honor our elders by
carrying on that struggle
don't let their sacrifices be in vain
that's why it's important for all of us
to be here today to show that work
together that were unified that we have
that and I hope okay and then Kapernick
wrote on Twitter spent the morning at
indigenous people's sunrise ceremony on
the 50-year anniversary of the
occupation of Alcatraz the US government
has stolen over 1.5 billion acres of
land from indigenous people thank you to
my indigenous family I'm with you today
and always okay
it is certainly worthwhile to recognize
that the that the United States is based
on European peoples coming to land that
they did not originally discover there
are people here already and then taking
over that land it is also important to
recognize that is the entire history of
human migration over the course of all
of human history literally all of it and
that before the Europeans even arrived
on this continent there were plenty of
people who were colonizing each other's
lands that were internecine warfare
between Native American tribes there
were people who are colonizing other
people's land this has been happening
throughout history to single out
European colonization of the Americas
has a unique evil in the history of the
world is simply ridiculous and not only
is it ridiculous it's particularly
ridiculous on Thanksgiving which is a
day specifically designated to be
tolerant and open Thanksgiving is a day
that was specifically created in order
to recognize the common humanity between
Native Americans and European peoples
who arrived on the continent this it's
just it's a ridiculous take on American
history a context-free take on American
history but unfortunately it is this
sort of view of America that is
splitting the country right now it's one
of the things that really is splitting
the country I think that it also goes to
the 16:19 project for example which is
something that the New York Times was
pushing you remember that the New York
Times pushed the the so-called 1619
project the idea the United States was
not founded in 1776 it was founded in
1619 with the original arrival of
African slaves on the American continent
being brought by European slave traders
okay there's only one problem with that
even historians recognize now the 1619
project is basically a bunch of garbage
James McPherson who is a civil war
historian he wrote a very famous book
called battle cry of freedom which is a
terrific book by the way if you everyone
reads in civil war history he said this
about the 1619
project he'd say I'd say almost from the
outside I was disturbed by what seemed
like a very unbalanced one-sided account
which lacked context and perspective on
the complexity of slavery which was
clearly obviously not an exclusively
American institution but existed
throughout history when slavery in the
United States was only a small part of a
larger world process that unfolded over
many centuries in the United States -
there was not only slavery but also an
anti-slavery movement so I thought the
account which emphasized American racism
which is obviously a major part of the
history no question about it but a focus
so narrowly on that part of the story
left most of the history out he also
suggested the idea that racism is a
permanent condition it's just not true
it doesn't account for the
countervailing tendencies in American
history
opposition to slavery and opposition to
racism has been an important theme in
American history and it's not just
Macpherson who's been complaining about
the 1619 Project Gordon wood who's
another Pulitzer Prize winner on the
Revolutionary War he said that he was
surprised by the scope of the sixteen at
nineteen project he said it is so wrong
in so many ways
and yet that sort of false history that
is being taught to the American people
by idiots like Colin Kaepernick and then
supposed knowledgeable people like
Howard Zinn and then being pressed
forward by politicians who bowed to it
it's really horrible for the country if
you want to have an American unity I'm
writing a whole book on this right now
if you want to have any sort of American
unity there's certain ties that have to
bind us together a basic understanding
of the American philosophy the creedal
truths of what it means to be American
which are basically embodied in the
Declaration of Independence the idea
that all men are created equal and that
we have equal rights and that those
rights include rights to life liberty
and property and the pursuit of
happiness right those are basic creedal
American truths those have been twisted
away from us we have to share a history
we have to believe that we're all part
of the same stream of history yes some
of us were were victimized in that
history and some of us our grandparents
were the aggressors in that history but
we're all part of that same history
because we're all part of the same story
we're all part of the same country and
yet what we are seeing now is an attempt
to revise history and divide Americans
from each other by making us permanent
identity groups that are simply
victimizing each other through
hierarchies of power what we're watching
right now is that the ties that bind us
in terms of our understanding of rights
a culture of rights rights expressed in
the bill of rights those rights are
being overthrown on a daily basis by
people who believe that those rights as
expressed in the
rights are actually just an expression
of people attempting to cram down their
own power view of politics and so for
example the right to free speech is
merely powerful people expressing
themselves and non powerful people being
silenced so we have to silence the right
to free speech through hate crimes
through hate speech laws and through
campaign finance reform we have less
speech is the answer that we're taking
all of the ties that bind us together
and then we are ripping them apart and
then we're ripping them apart and we're
celebrating as we do this on the Left
unfortunately a perfect example of this
today there's a piece by a guy named
Damon Young who's the author of a book
called what doesn't kill you makes you
blacker and it's in the New York Times
it's called in defense of woke and he
talked about why woken us is good now
understand the fray the the word woken
us you have to sort of understand we're
woken us comes from woke originally was
a sort of mocking term a derisive term
that was used to describe people who
believed in conspiracy theories they
were woke to the conspiracy right but it
has migrated so that now it's a term of
of praise because if you are woke to the
American system you see how evil
inherently the American system is and
therefore you are woke otherwise you are
asleep and you'll see this is what the
New York Times op-ed today is praising
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about the earbuds that
you are using to listen to this show so
are using the old-fashioned ones you
know the ones with the wires they get
all tangled up you put them in your
pocket every time you take them out you
have to spend half an hour trying to
untangle them so you can plug them into
your phone or are using a really
expensive pair of earbuds and you're
gonna lose one of them and then you have
to replace them and why don't you get a
great pair of earbuds wireless earbuds
they're not gonna cost you a fortune I'm
talking about ray cons ray con just
released their best model yet the e25
they have six hours of playtime seamless
bluetooth pairing more base a more
compact design that gives you a nice
noise isolating fit ray cons wireless
earbuds are incredibly comfortable they
are perfect for on-the-go listening and
for taking phone calls I love my redcon
earbuds also because they have specific
fits they give you a bunch of different
fits they give you like a almost looks
like a metal credit card that has on it
a bunch of different pieces that you can
attach to the ear buds that it fits
perfectly in your ear you've heard me
talk about how the company was
co-founded by celebrities like like Ray
J and celebrities like Jerry Smith are
obsessed with Ray Khan's will now go
check it out
see what the hype is about get 15% off
your order at buy rake on Comm
Ben that's bu IRA ycl ENCOM / Ben for
15% off rake on wireless earbuds by
Raycom comm / Ben go check them out
right now by rake on comm / Ben okay so
this op-ed in the New York Times really
is indicative of a certain worldview
that is gaining credence and tearing
apart the country it's called in
defensive woke by Damon young does
Donald Trump and his supporters want the
rest of us to stay asleep you see if you
want to talk about American history in
positive ways if you see America as a
generally good development if you see
capitalism as a generally good
development it's because you want people
to stay asleep
everybody got has to get woke everybody
has to wake up so Damon young writes
it was quite really that feeling I had
in the months after the 2016
presidential election where I convinced
myself I do everything possible in the
next four years to prevent Donald Trump
from becoming normalized it was our duty
to never stop shouting about his
abnormalities and I believed that this
conscientiousness had an unlimited
bandwidth I'd be obstinate and
cantankerous I'd be unflinching I'd be
resolute the fate of the Republic
depended on it but there I was on a lazy
Saturday three years later sitting in my
living room choosing to binge watch
Queen sugar instead of recaps of the
impeachment inquiry if I hadn't been
doing that I would have browse Zillow to
scout shelving space ideas for
open-concept kitchen either way why
might a stain for the president and his
supporters remains my capacity for hyper
consciousness has faded
I don't possess the stamina for the sort
of vigilance necessary to stay cognizant
of everything he's doing nor do I wish
to someone has to do it though and I'm
just not woke enough drat there is that
word woke rarely has a colloquialism had
as many mutations woke described as
racial awareness and cynicism so extra
it bordered on parody where you're so
awake that your third eye saw things
that aren't there the movies I'm gonna
get you sucka and don't be a menace to
South Central while drinking your juice
in the hood satirize this concept each
films most racially conscious character
was either married to a white woman or
willing to trample assist her to get to
one also woke was used exclusively by
black people to refer to other black
people it was our word because only we
were mindful enough to recognize when
that pro blackness was a performance as
the Ott's approached by 2000 the term
started to lose its racial connotation
becoming a catch-all instead for any
sort of progressive behavior
you were woke if you recycled or maybe
just retweeted an infographic on the
virtues of recycling white people were
deemed woke some painfully even took it
upon themselves to be the arbiters
focus and now well woke floats in
linguistic purgatory of terms coined by
us that can no longer be said on
ironically what was a complement just a
few years ago has become at best in I
roll mostly though it's used as a
pejorative though Maher seems to
consider woke Ness his personal
albatross as he's apparently blind to
the paradox of getting paid likely
millions of dollars a year to complain
about what he believes he's no longer
allowed to say progressives have to be
careful not to be so woke that will
scare moderates into voting for Donald
Trump Warren usually white male
colonists in every major American
newspaper when the beloved and iconic
Deadspin was effectively killed this
fall haters crawled out of the
Internet's crevices
cheering the demise of a marriage of
sports and woken us they considered
sacrilegious well actually it was
effectively committed suicide with its
own wellness but here is the point of
this very silly column these are the key
paragraphs this columnist suggests today
when I turn on the news and attempt to
slog through the impeachment inquiry I'm
reminded of some of the inane conspiracy
theories my woe cast college classmates
considered gospel there was the Tommy
Hilfiger one where we shouldn't buy his
clothes because he went on Oprah and
expressed disgust at black people
wearing them
there is the Timberland one where we
should stop buying those boots because
the emblem a tree represents at
lynchings these conspiracies could be
debunked with superficial research but
even as we'd roll our eyes at them for
believing these untruths we knew they
weren't wrong about America they just
had bad information that's the key
sentence right there that's the key
sentence for so many people on the
quote-unquote woke left every horrible
thing you could possibly come up with to
say about America maybe it's not right
but it's justified I don't take them
literally but take them seriously in
other words if it's a bad conspiracy
theory about the United States if it is
a context-free interpretation of
American history if the idea is that
America is universally the worst and so
we just sort of craft the fact pattern
in order to meet that end that's
justified because after all the point is
correct America is terrible so in other
words this person is saying that yes
Vulcanus used to encompass this sort of
conspiratorial ISM but conspiratorial
ISM is not unjustified in a country
where America is conspiratorial a racist
right he says that sure I mean we can we
can point out that some of these
conspiracy theories were
my Tommy Hilfiger or the timberland
boots but the Tuskegee experiments it
happened and COINTELPRO did happen in
red lining did happen and gerrymandering
is happening and black people were
targeted for subprime lending we are
arrested and incarcerated today a wildly
disproportionate rates while the
perpetually woke are dismissed
they're also the Canaries in our coal
mines alerting us to the dangers we
might be too drowsy to see right that's
that's the key right there
whatever you say that's bad about the
country is justified because those are
just people with highly attuned and
tonight and because their antennae are
so highly attuned they can see the evils
in American society where you cannot and
so that's why we should be paying
attention to people who make crazed
claims about the nature of the United
States and American history because in
the end they're just they're just the
bleeding edge right I mean they're just
the tip of the sphere and even in that
even in that paragraph where this
columnist is trying to put together all
the things that do happen he puts
together a bunch of things that did
happen and a bunch of claims he's making
about now and now all claims he's making
about now
are true so for example he says the
tuskegee experimented happen correct
and they said gerrymandering is
happening well gerrymandering has always
happened I mean there is nothing new
about gerrymandering the claim the
gerrymandering is purely racial is not
completely justified and the idea that
it's happening now as opposed to then is
silly in fact gerrymandering has been
happening through it's named after
Elbridge Gary who's one of the founders
and what are you talking about
when he conflates redlining from the
1970s and 1980s with arrest rates that
are disproportionate today
disproportionately but not just
proportionate in terms of crime that is
a conflation that does not make any
sense and so this column ends today
however the President of the United
States is is possibly involved in a
multinational scheme to suppress votes
discredit rivals and threaten
whistleblowers this fevered room feels
like the premise of a John Grisham novel
that his editor rejected for being too
absurd but I'm bored out of my mind with
the impeachment proceedings and would
rather watch my shower faucet drip or
perhaps just go to bed early and catch
up on some sleep and when I find myself
giving the insufficiently woke a hard
time I remember someone has to stay
awake this is an article in The New York
Times specifically accusing the
President of the United States of quote
a multinational scheme to suppress votes
discredit rivals and threaten
whistleblowers to suppress votes he's
gonna have to explain that one but again
every conspiracy is justified because in
the end America is a very bad place and
you see this sort of conspiracy
conspiratorial ISM across across the
west unfortunately a belief at the West
is uniquely terrible place in fact
there's an article from Project
Syndicate org written by Greta Thun Berg
who is of course the sixteen-year-old
climate change activists who took who
sailed over here to lecture us all about
carbon emissions and Louisa neubauer and
Angela Valenzuela and this column
basically suggests that all of the talk
about climate change is really not about
climate change it's about the evils of
the West generally write this column
says for more than a year children and
young people from around the world have
been striking for the climate we've
launched a movement that defied all
expectations with millions of people
lending their voices and their bodies to
the cause okay I'm sorry
like you marching is not gonna quit
lending your body to the cause since no
one was actually putting your body in
danger these these folks including Greta
thon Brook said we did not do this
because it was our dream but because we
didn't see anyone else taking action to
secure our future and despite the vocal
support we have received from many
adults including some of the world's
most powerful leaders we still don't
striking is not a choice we relish we do
it because we see no other options
countless negotiations have produced
much typed but ultimately empty
commitments from the world's governments
the same governments that allow fossil
fuel companies to drill forever forever
more oil and gas and burn away our
futures for their profit by the way I
just would like to point out here that
carbon-based fuels are one of the great
causes of increased world prosperity
over the past fifty to sixty years not
in the West okay in the second world and
the third world and developing countries
but here is the real point the real
point is that these these kids are
calling Greta fun Bergen and the other
people wrote this column they are not
just calling for change on climate
change this is part of a broader
worldview it's part of a broader rubric
that suggests that the West is
responsible for all global ills quote
that action must be powerful and
wide-ranging after all the climate
crisis is not just about the environment
and here we go it is a crisis of human
rights of justice and a political will
colonial racist and patriarchy
systems of oppression have created and
fueled it you're gonna have to explain
how sexism is responsible for climate
change that one you're gonna have to
explain to me that if women didn't run
the world what we would have solar power
that if women around the world we'd have
solar power somehow we would have broken
the we would have broken the The Da
Vinci Code we would have figured out how
to provide cheap nuclear and solar power
that surpassed the rates of carbon-based
fuels colonial racist and patriarchal
systems of oppression have created and
fueled it we need to dismantle them all
our political leaders can no longer
shirk their responsibilities
you wonder why folks on the right are
sort of suspicious of the climate change
movement it's because of nonsense like
this if you just want to claim that
there are environmental consequences to
the use of carbon-based fuels that's an
argument you want to suggest you want to
dismantle basically the entire Western
system and condemn it as entirely evil
simply because you don't like it and
then blame car a climate change yes
that's radical stuff and it is leading
to a crack up in Western civilization
we'll get to more of this in just one
second because the election of 2020 is
going to be largely about this conflict
of visions and elections all over the
world they're going to be about this
conflict division so we'll get some more
of that in just one second first okay I
got to tell you about the world's best
Christmas gift yeah the world's best
kinda it is just the best gift if you
have a spouse okay dudes if you have a
lady in your life and you're looking for
the best gift to get them a string of
pearls okay pearls are a fantastic
fantastic gift I got one for my I get
pearls for my wife actually on a fairly
somewhat regular basis and there's only
one place that I trust for pearls it's
called the pearl source it's a company
that I know well I I know the owner okay
and the owner is just a great dude you
get the highest quality pearl jewelry it
up to 70% off retail prices 70% off
retail prices for fine pearl jewelry and
by the way pearls I mean you wanna talk
about a jewelry that lasts the test of
time it would be those pearls right it
my wife will hand her pearls down to my
daughter that these are these are jewels
that last forever if you need it quickly
for the holidays no problem the pearl
source offers free two-day shipping on
every single order everything comes
beautifully packaged in the elegant
jewelry box it's ready to be given as a
gift like right out no hassle 60 day
money back guarantee so this is
risk-free you get it you don't like II
just return it it's great plus with more
than 20 years in the pearl business
and over 5,000 five-star reviews you can
be sure you are buying from a trusted
retailer plus again I know the people
who are on the company it is a fantastic
trustworthy company do not overpay for
jewelry at your local jewelry store
don't wait until the day before
Christmas and then rush on out to the
mall and then pay 70% more than you
could if you just went to the pearl
source go to the pearl source save up to
70% off retail prices you can shop for
everybody on the Christmas lift on the
Christmas list your wife your mom your
sister yourself for a limited time
listeners to my show can take 20% off
your entire order which is amazing just
go to the Pearl source.com slash been
again the Pearl source calm / been enter
promo code been a checkout for 20% off
your entire order if you want fine pearl
jewelry at the best prices online like
the best prices go straight to the
source the Pearl source the Pearl source
calm / been enter promo code been at
checkout so they know that we sent you
and man you're gonna get a great deal
20% off your entire order and you're
gonna be saving 70% off anyway off
retail prices because that's just and
the jewelry is beautiful the pearl
source calm / been enter promo code been
at checkout okay so more on the conflict
divisions that are rising in the West in
the United States abroad I mean Western
civilization may be on the verge of a
crack up specifically because all of the
ties that bind us are being frayed cord
by cord they're being cut I'll get to
that in just one second first Friday was
crazy if you didn't catch it we put
together a Black Friday promo or all of
our plans over at daily we're calm all
the subscription plans were 50% off we
learned something you really like
coupons more of you became subscribers
on Friday in a single day than in any
given month history o fire which is
amazing and then Saturday come along
Shabbos for me but I found out after our
customer support team was very busy a
lot of you missed the deal on Friday and
you wanted to honor it's that you want
us s to still honor the deal lots of
current subscribers were confused about
whether or not it worked on upgrades so
we are now bringing back the deal that's
right one more day one more day of this
magnificent incredible promotion when
you become a subscriber to daily wire
comm today you get 50% off when you use
the promo code DW 50 that's d-w 50 and
you're an insider you get access to our
live shows two additional hours of me
every single thing which is jet-like
only my wife gets additional hours of me
every single day alongside many other
things when
you are an insider plus you get all of
that and this the glorious leftist
here's tumbler cast your eyes upon it
despair that you have it not with our
new tear of all access you get to chat
with me and the rest of our team here at
Daily wire comm I can't like when you
asked Nolan's question usually just get
back a blank response but I can't vouch
for that to clarify for current
subscribers you can use this for
upgrades yes you can yes yeah
so what are you waiting for get over to
Daly wire.com use the promo code DW 50
before time it runs out we're not
running of that cyber Tuesday nonsense
this right now today last chance
DW 50 go over daily wire calm slash
subscribe and use code DW 50 and we are
extending that 50% off deal to all of
our plans and it works for upgrades to
check us out daily we're calm slash
subscribe we're the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
okay so this is a conflict that is
breaking out across the West again the
view of Western history Western
civilization institutions like
capitalism that have raised more than
half the globe from abject sheer
starvation level poverty in the last 40
years alone and there's a group of
people in the West you don't like any of
this and want all of it to go away and
see everything through a glass darkly
every single development in the West is
seen as an inherent bad and so you have
idiots like Mark Ruffalo who's earned
millions of dollars saying lines that
other people wrote for him on a screen
and he tweeted out the other day it's
time for an economic revolution
capitalism today is failing us killing
us and robbing from our children's
future really capitalism is killing us
capitalism has allowed 7 billion people
to live on planet Earth that's what
capitalism has done capitalism has
allowed the child mortality rate on
planet Earth to drop dramatically
capitalism has allowed people to live to
have families to not die at age 30 and
Mark Ruffalo a very very wealthy actor
sitting in his LA penthouse presumably
is talking about capitalism is failing
us and killing us and robbing from our
children's future absolute insanity any
time Mark Ruffalo feels like donating
his entire paycheck to the third world
and then getting right with Karl Marx he
can do it it's it's just amazing it's
just amazing by the way
he was browsing as of 2017 a ten million
dollar renovated Upper West Side
brownstone so that that's that's sounds
like a guy who really hates capitalism
he tweeted out a piece from Time
magazine called how America's elites
lost their grip all about how capitalism
has failed all of us and how socialism
is now the wave of the future again if
you are standing against the capitalist
system and then you propose that you're
standing in favor of human beings you're
gonna have to square those things and
don't give me that the countries of of
Sweden and Denmark and Finland are
somehow socialist paradises
if you want exorbitant tax rates
starting at 60 grand a year and if you
still want to live in a free market
system that's a free market system ma'am
okay if you ask the people from Sweden
and Norway whether they are living in a
free market system they will tell you
they are living in a free market system
the government does not own all the
means of production but the fact is
that this conflict over vision over what
America stands for what the West stands
for is continuing to resonate across
across the West and it is really
dangerous it's really dangerous because
ideally you'd have two sides that both
agreed on fundamental principles they
just disagreed about how to get to the
goal and that'd be the idea is that you
have everybody agreeing that Western
civilization is a pretty wonderful place
that free market capitalism is an engine
of growth some disagreements about what
government should take care of and what
government should not take care of some
disagreements on sort of marginalia
you'd have some disagreements on foreign
policy it has some disagreements on the
nature of of just how much to cast blame
on American history as opposed to credit
American history but a basic
understanding that America is a pretty
incredibly wonderful place by any sort
of historical or contemporaneous
standards right there'd be that basic
agreement but that does not exist it
does not and increasingly it is not
existing you can see this in in Great
Britain as well by the way in the
conflict over the London Bridge killer
for those of you who missed it over the
over the Thanksgiving Day weekend there
was a a terrorist who used a convicted
terrorist he'd actually served time in
jail he murdered two people on London
Bridge on Friday it turns out that he
was released early Boris Johnson who is
currently the prime minister and is
running for prime minister again in the
new elections that are about to happen
over there he said the reason this
killer was out on the streets was
because of automatic early release which
was brought in by a leftist government
he said I've only been in office for a
hundred and twenty days he says we take
a new approach meanwhile Jeremy Corbyn
was suggesting that convicted terrorists
should not necessarily serve their full
sentences he suggested that it would be
a mistake to reintroduce who tries to
kill people on London Bridge that you
should have to stay in jail for a while
the the killer in this case was a
convicted terrorist he was 28 years old
he was wearing a fake suicide vest in
wielding at knives he went on a rampage
at a conference on criminal
rehabilitation on the irony a conference
on criminal rehabilitation beside London
Bridge police said that this terrorist
had been previously convicted of
terrorism offences but was freed early
from prison Labour leader Jeremy Corbyn
who's an open communist at this point he
said it's
pens on the circumstance it depends on
the sentence but crucially it depends on
what they've done in prison so he wants
to continue to let people out of prison
and then here is a and his general his
general belief Jeremy Corbyn is the West
bares some sort of responsibility for
every sin on earth including the sins of
terrorists who after all are simply
responding to the Western predations
that have been so prevalent over the
course of the globe now all of this is
leading as I say to tremendous political
polarization and you see people like
Thomas head so who is a data-driven and
am interesting columnist over at the New
York Times desperately trying to cling
to the ideal and I'll give him credit
for this she's trying to cling to the
ideal that liberals in the United States
and abroad that they do not hold
completely separate visions of what the
world should be then people who are not
of the left so and so has a piece in the
New York Times called liberals do not
want to destroy the family or Society
for that matter how did this
preposterous idea leap to the forefront
of conservative thinking okay well I've
just given you about about half an hour
on how this quote-unquote preposterous
idea wept to the forefront of
conservative thinking and it is because
you have leading politicians in the
Democratic Party and abroad you have
leading media members who are
specifically spending every single day
talking about the innate evils of
Western systems it's because grave
changes brought about by the social left
in the United States have had deep
abiding ramifications for American life
and the left has not not only not
apologized for those things but has
attempted to accelerate the pace of
social change to the point where they
are now talking about obliterating the
distinctions between male and female
completely so that a male can become a
female a female can become a male and if
you disagree then you're a bigot and
Thomas head soul is sitting there going
why do these conservatives think that
people are tearing down institutions why
would people think that the left is
trying to destroy because Greta Thun
burg had a piece over the weekend in
which she talked about how basically the
West was a series of colonialist
patriarchal and racist institutions that
needed to be torn out at the root to
save us all from drowning thanks to
global warming maybe that may be because
one of the hottest political candidates
on the 20/20 scene is sitting there
nodding while a reverend suggest to him
that illegal aliens should be able to
cross into the United States on a moral
level because Texas used to belong to
Mexico maybe that
it's like this is not an evidence free
situation it's not that the right is
simply making things up about what the
left things the left has been fairly
clear about what it thinks on a variety
of these issues and it's particularly
true of cultural elites now where ENSO
is right is that if you ask mainstream
liberals if you ask most people who are
constituents constituents what they
think of America I still think that most
quote-unquote mainstream liberals
believe that America is a great place by
polling data this is true by the way
if you ask most mainstream liberals
whether they believe that capitalism is
a good thing
most will still say yes if you ask them
whether they believe in the American
flag in apple-pie and motherhood they
will say yes but the elites in the
democratic institutions in the higher
echelons of media in the halls of power
increasingly they don't believe this and
on Twitter they certainly don't believe
this the media elite on Twitter who have
created this woke echo chamber for
themselves they don't agree with this
they don't and so people are reacting to
the thought leaders as they should
because the fact is that thought leaders
lead those are the people who have
outsized media impact so Thomas head so
has this whole piece then he suggests
that Attorney General William bar who
warns in his speech at Notre Dame on
October 11 that secular liberalism had
unleashed quote licentiousness the
unbridled pursuit of personal appetites
at the expense of the common good he
said that there's a glaring incongruity
how could power bar person possibly
failed to recognize there is no better
example of a man an unbridled pursuit of
his own appetites than his boss okay
well this is not about Trump I love how
the left tries to turn everything into a
referendum on Trump Trump is a perfect
example of somebody who is a social
liberal except on issues like abortion
right Donald Trump is not somebody who
believes in traditional standards of
family obviously this is not somebody
who believes in traditional moral
boundaries with regard to sexual
behavior obviously that's true
but the right properly sees Trump as a
bulwark against the left wholesale
onslaught on these values themselves the
fact that Trump doesn't abide by them on
a personal level or maybe even care
about some of those values on a personal
level does not mean that he is not a
tool to stop the left in its ongoing
drive to destroy fundamental basic
institutions but Thomas head soul says
and the forces of secularism press on
with even greater militancy that the the
the message that Bart is putting out
it's part of our new drive by social
conservatives to demonize liberal elites
this theme underpins the new book by
Mary Oberst at a senior research fellow
at the faith Andreessen Institute Primal
Scream's have a sexual revolution
created identity politics the
alterations of traditional family
structure and the social order brought
forth by the sexual revolution
uber stat rites have simultaneously rain
down destruction on the natural habitat
of the human animal with radical results
we are only beginning to understand the
assault on liberal elites also dominates
wild liberalism failed by Patrick
Jeannine and the words of Robert George
professor of jurisprudence and director
of the James Madison program and
American ideals and institutions at
Princeton he says in practice many if
not most liberals are as deeply
disturbed by family dysfunction as
conservatives but they are not ranting
about it instead of promoting the kind
of Anarchy described by Barr and others
on the right scholars on the left now
acknowledge that the sexual revolution
and personal autonomy movement had
significant costs as well as notable
gains well I'm not seeing that from a
lot of folks on the political after you
I'm sure there are scholars who have
come out and pointed out that oh yes it
seems the one we completely wrecks the
ideal of the family back in the 1950s
and 60s and suggested as third wave
feminists did that family situations
were many concentration camps and that
isn't that is a direct paraphrase if
there is such a thing there is it's an
actual paraphrase of feminist literature
now they're coming around to the idea
that maybe that was damaging oh well
good for them good for them except you
don't hear that ever oh you hear from
the left is that the Conservatives evil
Republicans they want to bring us back
to those dysfunctional Leave It to
Beaver family ideals of the 1950s that
is the message being promoted hey in a -
in a 2015 study pew a liberal think tank
reported the percentage of children
under 18 living with two parents in
their first marriage fell from 73
percent in 1960 to 46 percent in 2014
yes but the fact that pew reported it
and it's a liberal think tank does not
change the fact that it was liberals who
drove that change in the first place the
hell is Edsel talking about and then he
says there's the fact that it is
well-educated often secular liberal
elites so detested by social
conservatives who are reviving the
traditional two-parent family with
declining divorce rates and a commitment
to combine forces to invest in their
children okay well there is a
correlation between economic success if
this is the point
economic success and living in a stable
two-parent household and creating stable
two-parent households for your children
that is true but Charles Murray wrote a
very famous book called coming apart in
which he talked about how denizens of a
sort of rich liberal elite areas were
preaching values entirely at odds from
the lifestyles they were living and how
this was bleeding downs the population
so Edsel tries to make the case that we
all agree that families are good we all
agree on basic social principles and
conservatives are crazy to think that
the left is pushing on this stuff and
then in the same newspaper they'll talk
about how drag queens are gonna take
down Trump how drag queens story our is
gonna fix America about how males can be
females and females can be males and we
need to reset the standards of what
constitutes bigotry in the United States
about how those who suggest the
traditional family is in fact superior
to non-traditional family in terms of
both the effects on children and the
effects on the spouses that if you point
this out you're a bigot it again I wish
that Ed Souls world were the reality I
wish that Edsel were the leader of the
Democratic Party unfortunately he is not
unfortunately he's not and we're
starting to see by the way and this
break out into the open in the views
that people have of Joe Biden so Joe
Biden tends to be a guy who's more on
the Thomas edsel side of this conflict
the Joe Biden is running in Iowa and
he's being derided for the fact that he
has a quote unquote boomer and it's not
going great for him so he was
campaigning in Iowa he's fading in Iowa
in the polls and there's a famous
picture that is now going around of Joe
Biden standing next to some dude and I
who who's completely ignoring him raised
at a cafe and Joe Biden is looking down
at him and the guys like I got better
things to do man I'm watching TV like
you can see he's watching the football
game
he hasn't cared of Joe Biden standing
next to him who's asked about that he
said yeah Iowa is Republican territory
why do I care about Joe Biden but the
fact is that Joe Biden is being derided
by members of his own party for being
too old out of touch his his his slogan
in Iowa has been no more malarkey he's
on what he calls his no more malarkey
tour and he's being mocked for all of
that because he's supposedly out of
touch to be in touch means to call
Michael Harriet over at the root and
basically apologize for having rational
viewpoints on inequality in America so
long as it pleases Michael Harriet the
unn
the the unwell thing to do is to be a
fan of Joe Biden who seems to be a sort
of fan of traditional Americanism even
if he has been an agent of I would say
radical social change in a variety of
areas so Biden is perceived as fading
but his popularity among the Democratic
base honestly I see that sort of is a
hopeful sign for the fact that there are
a lot of Democrats who don't believe in
the more radical agenda of the
Democratic Party unfortunately he is a
bad vessel for this movement and so you
end up with Joe Biden talking about
hairy legs on the campaign trail and by
the way you know I sit on the stand and
to get hot I got lolly I got hairy legs
that turned that that that that that
turned blonde in the Sun and the kids
used to come up and reach in the pool
and rub my leg down
so it was trade and then watch the hair
come back up again they look at so I
learned about roaches I learned about
kids jumping up my lap and I've loved
kids jumping on my lap um that um yeah
it's not going so great for the old
guard Democratic Party but at least
Biden's durability as a candidate that
is mostly reliant on the Edsel point of
view which again I hope wins out okay
now we are approaching unfortunately the
end of the show but I would be remiss if
I did not sound off on this insane
interview between Molly gyeong fast who
has become just insufferable if she
wasn't already she's just insufferable
all right talk about somebody with Trump
derangement syndrome she has a piece in
The Daily Beast today that is an
interview with Lisa page now Lisa page
is best known as the person who is a an
FBI lawyer stooping Kira struck and the
two of them were texting each other
about how much they hated Trump
basically Trump has used this as a
talking point in his campaign pointing
out that there were members of the
so-called deep state who are out to get
him
from the very beginning well she has now
come out and done an interview a and and
Molly Chong fests interview with her is
just absolutely fawning says it's not
that often that you interview a subject
who has no interest in being famous but
recently I did just that when I sat down
with Lisa Paige the week before
Thanksgiving in my hotel room in
Washington DC
Paige of course is the former FBI lawyer
whose text message exchanges with the
agent Peter struck that belittle Donald
Trump and expressed fear at his possible
victory became international news there
were hijacked by Trump too few
his deep state conspiracy for nearly two
years since her name first made the
papers
she's been publicly silent I asked her
why she was willing to talk now honestly
his demeaning fake orgasm was really the
straw that broke the camel's back she
says the president called out her name
as he acted out an orgasm in front of
thousands of people at a Minneapolis
rally on October 11 here's what it
looked like when Trump supposedly
demeaned her by faking an orgasm which
again I don't know what your orgasms
sound like but this is a weird take on
an orgasm if this is supposedly an
orgasm months earlier Peters struck
remember he and his lover
Lisa Paige she's going to win ten
million to one she's gonna win and I'm
telling you Peter
I'm telling you Peter she's gonna win
Peter I love you so much I love you
Peter I love you too Lisa at least hello
Lisa Lisa
oh god I love you Lisa and if she
doesn't win Lisa we've got it insurance
policy Lisa will get that son of a gun
okay so she said that was it that was
what set her off and now she had to be
interviewed first of all if he is faking
orgasm that's funny
also yet you don't get to play the
victim she's playing the victim now you
don't get to play the victim after you
text with your lover you're both married
you're texting with your lover between
setting rendezvous points about how
you're gonna take down one of the
candidates for presidents in the United
States yeah you're not a victim you're
not a victim sorry that's not the way
this works okay time for a quick thing
that I like and then a thing that I hate
so things that I like if you have not
yet seen Ford vs. Ferrari it's terrific
it's terrific it's a really really good
movie Matt Damon and Christian Bale two
of our best actors and it is based on
the the Ford attempt in the mid-60s to
win LeMond which is the 24 hour race
though the way it works by the way it's
not one driver for 24 hours it is it is
one car that is raced for 24 hours which
means that it has to be a pretty durable
piece of machinery and the entire movie
is basically about Ford attempting to
overcome Ferrari and the entrepreneurial
and artistic spirit of individuals who
are attempting to do something cool
which is really what the movie is about
so it you want to talk about movies that
are really in praise of capitalism this
is a movie that is basically in praise
of capitalism you
though it tries to make the corporate
higher-ups the the villains of the piece
here is here is a little bit of the
preview it's terrific hates guys like us
because we're different we heard he's
difficult Ken no no Ken's a puppy dog
[Music]
it's Soho there's a problem the computer
will find it you get some scotch tape
and a ball of wool what are they doing
making your car faster
and be nominated for Best Actor one of
them will probably be nominated for Best
Supporting but both Damon and Bale are
terrific in this film the film is
beautifully directed it's a
two-and-a-half-hour movie but it feels
like an hour and a half movie really
really first-rate definitely worth the
watch and a very cool American story
because America is a badass place with
fast cars and beautiful women it's a
fantastic fantastic country it really is
okay time for a quick thing that I hate
okay so there is an entire article in
The New York Times about why shade is
racist not kidding you shade why because
it turns out that in more impoverished
areas of the United States there is less
shade yes because you are packing
tenements together very often apartment
buildings it turns out in places where
people live on top of each other there
is less space I know very difficult to
understand suburbia more trees why cuz
there's more land in suburbia you're
spending more money to live out there
that's right but apparently this is a
sign of evil inequality and in LA this
is a big problem according to the New
York Times quote there is no end to the
glittering emblems of privilege in this
city but I do love the the lack of
ironic subtext in these New York Times
pieces Los Angeles has been governed by
Democrats basically my entire lifetime
with the brief exception of Richard
Riordan his mayor it is a an entirely
democratic City it is also turning into
a junkie it has been turning into a
junkie but because it is a liberal city
is a horribly horribly governed City and
so whenever they talk about glittering
emblems of inequality you might want to
look to I don't know the state and local
government which have been dominated by
Democrats basically since I was a
teenager anywhere near time says there's
no end to the glittering emblems of
privilege in the city
Tesla's clogged the freeways affluent
families scramble for coveted spots in
fancy kindergartens and up in the hills
of bel-air or a sprawling estate just at
the market for a record 225 million
dollars lush trees lined the streets
providing welcome relief from punishing
heat they say the Sun has always been in
the draw of LA but these days shade is
increasingly seen as a precious
commodity as the crises of climate
change and inequality converge see
because it implants a lot of trees in
heavily urban areas which happens to be
true of every heavily urban area
basically in the United States I mean if
you walk down the
Midtown Manhattan not a lot of shade
happening on those streets either the
difference is LA is real hot so if you
don't want to live here good news there
are buses every single Bay but
apparently you are supposed to the shade
is an inequality issue notice you want
to plant more trees I'm all for it
you under you to file light enjoy like I
think that that is something that is
totally worthwhile I am for more shade
but the fact that every single thing can
be chalked up to income inequality or
the fact that we are supposed to look at
every aspect of inequality as though it
is a problem with the quote unquote
system yes inequality has existed it
will exist it will continue to exist
even though you know what the difference
is now and before the fact is that we
have air conditioning in Los Angeles the
fact is that virtually everyone in the
United States including people who are
living in poverty at least has a unit
air conditioner and that's that's a
pretty big change from the 1920s and
1930s but the idea here is that we just
look at the trees and we know that
income inequality has come tell I guess
what was not in LA 70 years ago lots of
trees in downtown it's just yes it is
better to be rich than poor this has
always been true for all of human
history pointing out that fact does not
recommend a solution nor does it suggest
that the fact that it is better to be
rich than poor means that the problem
itself is that there are rich people and
people who are less rich the problem is
how do we get people to rise from
poverty not that they not that somebody
is a 225 million dollar estate in Bel
Air but how do we make life better for
the people in downtown folks in LA keep
thinking if they taxed at 225 million
dollar estate magically life in downtown
becomes better that ain't the truth by
the way the only thing that's made
downtown better in recent history has
been public private projects done with
literally tens of millions to hundreds
of millions of dollars in private money
in cooperation with the city of Los
Angeles but everything is an inequality
issue when you boil down everything to
inequality it basically the New York
Times is a drunk looking for the car
keys under the lamp the proverbial drunk
looking for the car keys under the under
the lamp right is that if they're not
there then it must be they don't exist
you're only looking where the light is
well four out for them every everything
exists in the light of inequality and
therefore if you're worried about shade
that's not a problem with bad city
planning that's not a problem with bad
city governance that's a problem that
there are so much people in some poor
people
well done New York Times you've really
hit the nail on the head already we'll
be back here later today with two
additional hours that do not forget head
on over to Daily wire , / subscribed
today today only use promo code DW 50 we
have cyber monday special amazing deals
go check us out right now otherwise
we'll see you here tomorrow I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Rebecca Dodd poets directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens associate producer Colton Haas
assistant director Pavel white house key
edited by Adam Sai events audio is mixed
by Mike Romina hair and makeup is my jl
l vera production assistant Nick Sheehan
the Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 a
Muslim terrorist goes on a rampage
climate activists admit environmentalism
isn't about the environment and Bernie
Sanders calls Christianity on American
we examine what all these three stories
have in common that all human conflict
is religious check it out on the Michael
Dahl show